der absturz der sojus rakete bringt die
raumfahrt ziemlich durcheinander nicht
nur dass jetzt die hälfte der besatzung
fehlt sondern auch der komplette plan
für die besetzung der crew auf der
internationalen raumstation iss kommt
jetzt erst mal durcheinander und
wichtige arbeiten bleiben liegen die
forschung läuft nur mit halber kraft und
ungeklärt bleibt jetzt auch erst einmal
das mysterium des loches in der sojus
kapsel klicks um science-fiction und am
ende dieses videos habe ich noch eine
hammer überraschung seid gespannt
herzlich willkommen ja das war wirklich
ein schock als die bilder um die welt
gingen sie erinnerten an die größten
katastrophen in der raumfahrt doch
dieses mal ging es für die besatzung der
sojus-kapsel gott sei dank glimpflich
aus niemand wurde verletzt was bleibt
ist ein riesiger finanzieller schaden
und eine ungewisse zukunft der raumfahrt
zurzeit weiß niemand was da passiert ist
und es stellt für die russische
weltraumagentur roskosmos eine absolute
katastrophe daraus kostenlos direktor
dimitri rogosin wurde erst im mai
ernannt um missstände beim tus programm
zu beseitigen und jetzt ist es noch viel
schlimmer und zwar viel viel schlimmer
nachdem in einer sojus-kapsel ein loch
gefunden wurde bei dem immer noch nicht
klar ist ob es ein produktionsfehler
oder sabotage war kommt jetzt eine noch
größere katastrophe hinzu die russische
technik um astronauten und astronauten
in den weltraum zu bringen funktioniert
nicht zuverlässig dem dazu kommt dass es
zurzeit aus der ganzen welt kein anderes
zuverlässiges system gibt um eben
passagiere in den weltraum zu bringen
lediglich china ist dazu in der lage
aber mit dem kommunistischen land
arbeitet weltweit kaum jemand zusammen
aber für den rest gilt weder die
kapselform beugen die cst 100 starliner
noch die crew drängen von spacex die
sind bisher für raumflüge mit besatzung
zugelassen
im juni 2009 10 soll die crew dragon zum
ersten mal beim an staaten die cst von
100 starliner im august die frage ist
jetzt wie schnell kann die ursache für
das unglück gefunden werden warum hat
sich ein booster nicht richtig
abgetrennt und die zweite stufe der
sojus rakete beschädigt oder
schnell ist eine der neuen kapseln am
start kann da irgendetwas beschleunigt
werden solange hier keine lösung
gefunden worden ist wird die crew um den
derzeitigen kommandanten alexander gerst
dort oben ausharren müssen
ein trost ist dass die versorgung mit
nachschub weiterhin gesichert ist die
vorräte an bord reichen auf jeden fall
noch bis april wenn aber das ist hier
keine lösungen findet dann muss komplett
neu geplant werden unter hochdruck
müssen jetzt die neuen kapseln in dienst
gestellt werden bis dahin oder bis die
sojus rakete wieder starten kann läuft
auf der ss alles im schneckentempo die
besatzung ist jetzt mit drei leuten nur
noch quasi halb so stark wie geplant und
wissenschaftliche experimente wenn jetzt
zwar weiterhin abgearbeitet aber nur mit
halbem tempo wichtige außeneinsätze
müssen jetzt erstmal entfallen das
bedeutet auch dass das loch in der sojus
kapsel nicht von außen inspiziert werden
kann
es bleibt also erstmal weiterhin
vollkommen unklar was da passiert ist
weiterhin hängt die frage wie ein
damokles schwert im raum war es sabotage
oder kaum weniger schlimm schlamperei
bei der produktion der kapsel alter
zeigt auf jeden fall wie verletzlich die
raumfahrtindustrie ist ein einziger
unfall bringt alles durcheinander
gut dass sieben jahre nach dem letzten
space shuttle flug 2011 endlich wieder
neu transportmittel ins weltall zur
verfügung stehen und wahrscheinlich bald
zum einsatz kommen wie wichtig die sind
hat sich jetzt gezeigt es wird also
spannend was in den nächsten wochen und
monaten geschieht ich bleibe dran so und
jetzt heißt es bescherung mein buch ja
zumindest ein teil dieses buches aus dem
rowohlt verlag ist von mir ein geschenk
ausgabe von hawkings eine kurze
geschichte der zeit mit einem sammelband
mit gedanken über seine bedeutung mit
artikeln von michio kaku harald lesch
reinhold beckmann und vielen anderen und
mir denken ohne grenzen und ja ich habe
über die bedeutung von hawking als
gewissen der menschheit der sich
gedanken über künstliche intelligenz die
zerstörung unserer welt und aliens
gemacht hat geschrieben ein super
geschenk also ein klick und zwar darauf
und ihr könnt es
bestellen ja und hier geht es weiter
drunter dafür auch draufklicken sabotage
auf der internationalen raumstation iss
also nicht vergessen super buch
draufklicken bis dann bleibt dran